hello everyone and welcome to the video
you've all been waiting for and the news
you've all been waiting for
it's a great day for chess it's a great
day for India but especially it's a
great day for a grandmaster Ramesh Babu
pragna and now as you all know you know
it's been all over the news ever since
like like last year will he become the
youngest Grand Master in the world and
although he he didn't become the
youngest Grand Master in chess history
he did become the second youngest in
grandmaster in chess history and also he
is the current youngest grandmaster
today so as you remember in 2017 prague
won his first Grand Master norm in the
world junior championship intervie Co
Italy and then his second the
grandmaster norm he won this year in the
farik Lyon faithful Memorial Tournament
in Greece and now in gray Dean Italy in
in order to say after eight rounds that
have been played in this very strong
tournament he has six and a half points
and he is tied in first place before the
last round with croatian grandmaster
even charged so this is one of the games
played in this tournament he faces the
very strong and talented Iranian
international master Ariane Kalani and
it's a very nice game I'm sure you're
gonna enjoy it so let's check it out so
Prague has the white pieces and he opens
with Knight to f3 the reti opening we
have Knight to f6 and now c4 also Prague
who doesn't enjoy the the Kings Indian
attack with the g3 but at this game he
decided he decided to go for something
different so c4 we have b6 g3 the trip
to b7 Bishop g2 g6 the for Bishop to g7
we have castles castles and now d5 also
possible is the Knight to c3 but then
black can immediately go for some for
some exchanges and white wants to keep
all the advantage so first d5 grabbing
more space and not allowing black any
exchanges we have Knight to e4 and now
Knight f2 d2 also creating a very nice
position and here avoiding the exchange
now golem it goes for nice to see 5 and
here it's a it's a completely new game
not available
in the database we have nice to be three
and now comes a five and nice to see
three also nightcap captors captors and
Queen b3 is very nice going for the
bishop developing the Queen but after up
to a seven it's not it's not all that
clear can white push for any advantage
here and Prabhu keeps everything on the
board you know not forcing anything so
Knight to c3 we have d6 and now Knight
study for Queen to d7 and now e4 e5 and
Knight comes to b5 so as you can see
both both Prague and Kalama are very
interested in a good fight and none of
the pieces have been exchanged and all
of the pawns are still on the board so
we have Knight B to a 6 a 3/8 f5 and now
f3 he captures on f5 with G captures on
f5 would also have been possible and in
fact it's very nice for white but maybe
black would would get a bit too much
here as black can now start pushing his
pawns and if we can figure out what to
do with this Knight and Bishop then
black will also be fine but Prague still
tries to keep everything in fact we have
f3 but now F captors on on e 4f captures
on e4 rope captures on f1 and now King
captors on f1 and here probably rook to
f8 check follow the unfollowed with King
to g1 is probably the best way to go
bring in the rook in the game with the
tempo but here after King captures on f1
we have c6 and ok we have B captures
Bishop captures and now probably goes
for King to g1 here it seems like black
black losses upon here but the immediate
Queen captures and these six would
actually lose the game for Prague oh so
he here what is this because of roof to
f8 check now we have kinked a king to g1
and now Bishop captures on b5 Knight
captures Queen captures
Knight captures and now comes the star
move Knight to b3 going for the rook if
you avoid this rook to be one then comes
rook to d8 what do you do with the night
after remove the night you get rook to
d1 check
blocks and now rock captors and you just
lost the piece so uh grabbing the point
immediately would lose the game for
Prabhu immediately so King to g1 and
here the d6 pawn it's a backwards pawn
and it's a weak point so Praga doesn't
mind he's gonna capture it either way
Knight to c7 now comes to Bishop to e3
Knight 7 to e6 we have before now a
captures a captures and now nice to a6
exchanging rocks doesn't really do all
that much for black Peter so night to a6
and now comes Knight to d5 and here
black is black is in such a terrible
position that there really isn't all
that much to do you cannot capture and
win upon here as knife captures on b6
would would immediately win you the game
the queen is attacked the rook is
attacked wherever you move a captures
here rocky still attacked the knight is
hanging and the knight is pinned so a
very hard position for black here
let me try tonight 8 to c7 and here we
have Knight beat captures on c7
rook captures on a8 is is the best move
and now Bishop to h3 simply destroys
blacks position but Prague evaluates the
position correctly and he he finds that
night B captures on c7 is also
completely winning because now you get
rook captures Queen captures and Knight
captures on c7 like a bishop cap for
some b6 Knight captures here he captures
on d5 and after Bishop moves now comes
b5 so what can you do here have to move
the bishop of course the bishop is under
attack bishop c2 and now comes Queen 2a8
with check King Bishop blocks and now
Bishop to e3
simply bring the bishop over here so it
can help defend the White King and now
you simply create a room for this pawn
to march forward there is no stopping
the b-pawn so black has to do something
drastically but there isn't all that
much to do go let me try screen to g4
maybe Queen to d1 can bring him some
ideas of a perpetual so first h3 making
room for the King on h2 and now there is
really nothing here
Queen to d1 check if you grabbed upon
you lose immediately then better to h6
there is no defense
Queen captures on on f8 so after h3 will
have Queen d1 check King moves and now
King to f7 you can't allow bash up to h6
to tie down the bishop on f8 Queen b7
check we have King to f6 Queen to c8 now
going of course
here for Queen to e6 King back to g7 and
now comes without further ado worship to
h6 check and it was in this position
that Iranian international master Ariane
ghulami
resigned the game what would follow is
King capture screen captures and now it
regardless of where you go with the King
you're gonna lose the game
h4 now comes King g4 if you go King h5
Bishop f3 wins the Queen so King here
and now Queen to h6 and there is no
defense against Queen to g5 checkmate
there are no checks there are no threats
there are no tricks here so it would be
pointless to even try anything here
now whatever black plays Queen g5 on the
next move will be checkmate
but after Bishop h6 the game continue no
longer and this is move 35 so yeah a
very nice game against the I believe
Balaam is almost 2500 rated so I believe
2490 so you know winning a game in 35
moves against such a strong player
definitely deserving deserving of its
third Grandmaster norm but yeah that was
the game and I do hope you enjoyed it
and here I prepared these are the
standings after 8 rounds of the of the
tournament here we have pregnant is tied
with even charge of Croatia with 4 in
first place with six and a half points
and then all the other players to follow
so that's quite an achievement as
Charlotte charge is the top seed in this
tournament and the charge is the
reigning champion of Croatia but also
the reigning European champion
so quite quite an achievement and also
here we have who are the youngest Grand
Masters in history as of as of now
so although pregnant that did not break
Corrigan's record here you can see that
circuit circuit Huracan
one here is the Grandmaster title at the
year at 12 years and 7 months then
there is now in second place with 12
years and 10 months then no the Rubik
abdul Sattar of uzbekistan 13 years and
one month party mario Negi of india 13
years and 4 months and magnus carlsen in
fifth place now at 13 years and four
months so very nice very nice standings
and you can see that out of the five
youngest run master's in history India
now claims two of them so maybe you know
maybe announcing a shift of power in the
future and also it was a very joyous day
of course it all happened yesterday so
you know how congratulations were
pouring in from all over the world world
all over the media portals the social
networks and you can see that even
former world champion and reigning rapid
the world champion Viswanathan Anand
also joined in the congratulations so
yeah that's basically it
once again huge congratulations to young
frog oh and you know achieving such such
greatness at such a young age it seems
that only sky is the limit for for the
young boy from Chennai so that's it for
this video as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
maybe maybe even I will create a poll
for my next series so we can check out
where to go from here so thank you all
and I'll see you soon